a statutory grape victim forced to pay
child support Nick Olivas became a
father at 14 a fact he wouldn't learn
for eight years while in high school all
of us had
some bedroom fun with a 20 year old
woman as he sees it now she took
advantage of a lonely kid going through
a rough patch at home
state law says a child younger than 15
cannot consent with an adult under any
circumstances making Olivas a great
victim all of us didn't press charges
and says he didn't realize at the time
that it was even something to consider
the two in their separate ways all of us
now 24 and living in Phoenix graduated
from high school went to college and
became a medical assistant then two
years ago the state served in with
papers demanding child support that's
how he found out he had a then
six-year-old daughter
it was a shock he said I was living my
life enjoying being young to find out
you have a six-year-old is unexplainable
it freaked me out he said he panicked
ignored the legal documents and never
got the required paternity test the
state eventually tracked him down all of
our city owes about fifteen thousand
dollars in bad child support and medical
bills going back to the child's birth
plus 10 interest
the state seized money from his bank
account garnishing his wages he wants to
be in his daughter's life and is willing
to pay child support going forward but
he says it's not right for the state to
charge him for fees incurred when he was
still a child himself for or for the
years he didn't know the girl existed
anything I do as an adult I should be
responsible for but as a teenager I
don't think so whoa the most well-known
case for a Kansas boy who at the age of
13 impregnated his 17 year old
babysitter under Kansas law a child
under the age of 15 is legally unable to
consent the Kansas Supreme Court in 1993
ruled that he was liable for child
support
California issued a similar State Court
ruling a few years later in the case of
a 15 year old boy who slept with the 34
year old neighbor in that case a woman
had been convicted in both cases the
state Social Services agencies that
pursued the case after the mother sought
public assistance
the Kansas Court determined that the
grape was irrelevant and that the child
was not owed to the rapist but rather to
the child what bothers me is this is
that in the case of a woman getting
grape she's able to choose that the man
is not in the life let them demand of
that did whatever he did he's I don't
want him to be in his life I don't want
to see the thought and everything and
stuff but the man doesn't have that
choice that's what [__] me up what I
mean if a woman that gets grape when she
was a kid and gets pregnant and keeps a
child right she's able to say I don't
want to see that person ever in my life
and I don't want to have contact I do
not want that person to have access or
child support and everything and stuff
on the other hand a man that gets great
doesn't want to have anything to do or
child services or anything to do doesn't
have that choice that's what's [__] up
a woman can choose I don't want to have
anything to do with that person you
don't have to pay this and that and that
just be over there but the man can't
he's going to be pursued he's going to
be pursued
to pay for the Mythic that she did
that's what's [__] up that's what's
even worse that's what's getting me out
of everything else that's what's [__]
up that he could be he could be this
happened to me when I was a child and
this and that I want to have nothing to
do with that I want to move on and he
can't he has to pay for her mistake so
it's like if she gets jailed he gets
jailed we already established the fact
that he cannot and he didn't have the
mind to say yes or no to consent to that
so she get a jail sentence he get a jail
sentence for 18 years 18 years that's
what's going on that's what [__] me up
more than anything so as I understand
it's actually not her pursuing him she
went to the state for public assistance
and the state said okay we'll give it to
you but we're gonna recoup it for
somewhere it doesn't matter it doesn't
it doesn't matter whether it's her or
him he could be like I never want to
have to do anything with that and the
states is like no you're gonna have to
pay you get a sentence too it was not
sure mistake but yeah you you do you you
go out there and you are not old enough
we could say at the same time you were
not old enough to consent but you're
you're you were old and yeah you just
you just paid you get a sentence too
whether it's the mom or the state it's
still the kid that is affected and that
that has to deal with that that has to
pay for a mistake that a grown-up did
that's what's messed up was a mistake
great being a child
that's not a mistake bro you know what
the [__] I'm into okay let's not play no
no it's not a play on worse that's not a
play on words
you kill somebody that's not a mistake
you regret somebody that's not a mistake
bruh okay whatever the hell happened in
the situation that you did your [__] up
is that better [__] up it's fine okay
she did a crime you get what I'm trying
to say that's not a mistake cool you
didn't accidentally land on a 14 year
old dick you know you're like we don't
know we wasn't there maybe acrobatics
was involved I don't know he managed to
bust so that's a long mistake [__]
anyways all that to say I'm just saying
just like when you kept saying I was
confused because I'm like who's making a
mistake yeah I'm sorry the lady the lady
[__] up that's what I mean she [__]
up her [__] up [__] up is a better word
that shoots [__] up I don't think [__]
up is a better word okay
[__] up sounds like you were trying to
do something
her crime her crime is that better does
that untrigger you it's not her crying
it's not about triggers the crime she
did it's not about trigger it's like
when you use words they have meanings
you understand that right so if you say
she made a mistake you do not even
realize it but you're making it almost
sound like oh you know sometimes women
just accidentally sleep with her yeah
it's not their fault
hormones and [__] you know he look good
and manly her crime he has to pay for
her crime yeah there you go is that
better yeah it is it actually is
she a criminal he has to be a great
person he has to pray for that and
that's a problem so he has a double he
has a tendency listen the victim has
also a sentence and that was me that
that's what [__] me up you don't have
to choose you don't have to imagine
having to pay child support before
you're even an adult he's paying child
support for years he wasn't even looking
and here's the thing for the years a
child is a walking receipt that she
engages in grape yes
oh he's a daddy well he was 13 when this
child was born you know I mean like
yes he didn't do anything but I feel
like the Statue of Liberty should
dictate that the state should charge her
anyways because there's no legal grounds
for this what are the legal grounds can
anyone tell me like the state can take
this case look at it see grape happened
and not press charges
does nobody else think that's [__] up
I don't care what the victim says he
could say he consented you can't
consider at that age because I'm
impossible I can't sleep with a 13 year
old and they're like oh there's no it's
not real
they should charge her now
yeah but if he ignore all the fact and
anything and stuff like that you know
what
I'm gonna tell you this as much as the
state is involved and yo you should pay
child support the state should be
involved in oh but by the way you also
raped him so you should go to jail
conduct with a minor is a felony the
statute of limitations prosecutes the
crime is seven years
they've been going after this
[__] for three years the kid is
six they've had time to do this whole
thing they just chose not to and they
probably
that's not his choice if you're a 13
year old you don't choose whether or not
you get to accuse a person that's not
how it works the prosecutor will just
charge they're not like hey little one
who was traumatized do you want to press
charges you think they asked they don't
give a [__] they'll ask for your
cooperation but they don't need it no
and they don't right there's a child
you're right like you can't even make a
defense nope
here's a thing you can't make a
defensive whether it happened or not
it's like and you claim to take DNA so
like what are we even talking about I
don't even know but what happens is the
state thinks like all right this
[__] didn't say nothing
and we need somebody to take care of
this child because we don't want to put
them in foster care so we gonna let it
slide no we don't want to check out
money you just have to ask yourself if
the world's rolls reverse would they do
that I don't know I don't know it seems
like
beyond the language of mistakes or [__]
ups or whatever the [__] is the reality
is
if a lady does some shady [__] there's a
lot of leeway given to people we've
covered already a few cases of women
doing stuff that was like what and they
let those [__] off free
so maybe there's another instance of
that but it's crazy to me that you make
that person pay child support for this
kind of thing
and during the years where they're still
in high school what the [__] am I
looking at
and you charge them interest I don't
even know yeah because you can pay
this [__] that's the kind of
[__] that's the kind of [__] I would run
away from America this [__] he
can't even work he can't even work but
he's like yeah you know at 13. oh no
get the [__] out of here
ice cream no get the [__] out of here
[Laughter]
to give 25 of them imagine my [__] had
a lemonade stand some some [__]
people to show up like
so checking in that book
she's thinking in the change box that's
that's us that's us who are you guys
Child Services
what do you want you're cut
that's what's happening think about that
yeah out here just drinking the lemonade
for free thanks we'll be back next month
that's crazy if I have to deal with
taxes as a kid I would have off myself
but anyways you know it's wild what
like if a woman
you know even in the most conservative
States if a woman is graped and she
wants to get an abortion like yes that's
fine we accept that right because it was
against her will there's many of them
who will say that most conservatives
like if she was raped they'll say that
but then here you have a man who is
graped
and they're saying it doesn't matter
well it's not exactly the same thing
what you're talking about is abortion
now we're not talking about abortion no
my point wasn't that they're the same
thing that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is that even the most
conservative places where they don't
believe in the right to choose
they would make the exception if
somebody was graped you get what I'm
trying to say yes but no I don't see
what you're trying to say how that links
to what it is well this man was graped
as well but he has absolutely no right
to choosing this kind of circumstances
but well man even in the most liberal
places men don't have the right to
choose which is which is the irony which
is the irony even for conservatives who
are a nurse they would give the Credence
to women to be able to choose no
circumstances if they're great but for
even the most liberal states like
California right a men would not have
the right to that no never because he's
also a dad you can do you could be two
things at the same time according to the
law I'm not saying it's right I'm not
saying it's right at all but according
to the law especially the fact that in
this case he didn't do anything so
basically according to the laws of the
uh the eyes of the law it's not great
because there was nothing that was done
thing is even if it was great
they still wouldn't do it that we
wouldn't have done anything right so
that's the thing that's [__] up with
that even if even if it was but at the
end of the day what it is is that these
two things he's a victim and he's also a
dad same thing as a like a woman that uh
gets grape and uh
keeps a child she's two things the
mother and also the victim so that's
pretty much I think that's where they
stand on that I think it's pretty much
stupid and that's crazy let us know what
you guys think in the comments yo